voilà voilà voilà poney ses caramels là
ils sont très bien ça devait bien pili
propre onze ans après il verse un peu de
ceci servez vous prenez en plein
d'espoir aujourd'hui
élection du président de la fête de
l'île aux enfants mais c'est parfait sur
celle là non plus il n'y a pas de fautes
d'orthographe à acteurs qu'yat-il
casimir vous voulez que je vous fasse
une petite danse et pourquoi tout à coup
tu veux me faire une petite danse
vous savez quand je suis candidat à la
présidence de la fête de l'île aux
enfants
pour sûr même qu'il n'y a plus que toi
et monsieur du snob côte et relie les
autres candidats se sont retirés il
avait peur d'être ridicule
ouais ben ils ont eu raison monsieur du
snop aurait bien fait d'en faire autant
on me dit non tu as bien versions de
toit oui parce que j'ai eu une grande
idée à bout et laquelle casimir j'ai
promis à tout le monde de faire ce qui
lui plairait s'ils votent pour moi alors
vous par exemple je vous ferai tous les
jours une petite danse comme ça va t'en
va pas par ne pas me tendre papa papa tu
en voilà
j'adore te voir danser casimir mais tu
es quand même un drôle de démagogues
allez allez mon vieux qu'il faut que je
me dépêche j'ai encore beaucoup d'
affiches apposées au revoir casimir a
factor et qu'est ce que c'est que ça et
il m'a traitée de démagogues
qu'est ce que c'est c'est c'est gentil
où c'est méchant
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous les
enfants un démagogue vous savez ce que
c'est vous croyez reprenez des bonbons
reprenait des bonbons vous savez les
enfants
si vous votez pour moi vous aurez tous
les jours des bonbons des nougats des
caramels du chocolat tout ça gratuit et
bien kazimierz et joyeux pour moi ce que
tu promets là tu veux ma perte
pourquoi julie mon mon programme
électoral ne te convient pas tu veux que
je te donne aussi des bonbons mais tu
sais bien que je gagne ma vie en vendant
des bonbons de chocolat et des caramels
ouais et alors là leur situe en
distribuer gratuitement
je ne pourrai plus vendre les miens je
n'ai plus qu'à partir j'en ai pas pensé
à ça mais mais j'ai une idée
écoute je distribuerai les bonbons
gratuitement les bonbons je t'aurais
acheter mais si tu avais beaucoup
d'argent ça sera une très bonne solution
pour moi mais ça ressemble fort à une
promesse de démagogues quoi pour toi
aussi tu me traites de démagogues
où est mon vieux à tout à l'heure il
faut que j'ouvre mon kiosque aux
démagogues démagogues j'aimerais bien
savoir ce que ça veut dire vous vous
avez une idée vous lorsque c'est aussi
embêtant c'est vraiment embêtant pas
savoir allez les enfants reprenaient
plein de bonbons un servez-vous bien
mais tu es en plein au poche voilà
bonjour casimir quoi qu'est-ce que ça
ira françois comment se passe sa
campagne électorale bien mais je
voudrais qu'on habille je t'écoute avec
plaisir voilà
regarde moi je te regarde dans mais
regardez moi bien mieux que sa tâche
était parfaitement regardes et tu n'as
remarque que rien non non a alors je ne
suis pas démagogue m'écoute casimir ça
ne se voit pas sur le visage de
quelqu'un quand il est démagogue
c'est uniquement une façon d'agir
ah bon parce que julie que le facteur
m'ont traité de démagogues et je ne sais
pas ce que ça veut dire écoute casimir
écoute malien
on dit de quelqu'un qu'il était magog
lorsqu'il essaie d'être élu ou
simplement de se faire bien voir par
tout le monde
en promettant des choses qui pourra pas
tenir par exemple offrir des bonbons et
des chocolats à tous les enfants du
jardin tous les jours c'est pas toi qui
fais à quelque chose d'aussi mâle noir
on aura sûrement pas vraiment fait un
bon bah écoute il faut que je m'en aille
j'ai deux ou trois choses à faire avant
d'aller voter à tout à l'heure
à tout à l'heure avec un bonjour casimir
ah ah bonjour monsieur du snab l'heure
décisive approche ce tout le monde
quitte le jardin pour aller voter
bon vent monsieur douce nab oh oui je
sais mais j'aurais du mal à gagner
l'élection
tu as fait le campagne électorale de
démagogues on vous a dit ça
oui mais je connais au moins une fois
que tu n'auras pas quoi
la mienne paix mais plus pourquoi
enfin vous devez voter pour moi je vous
promets de faire tout ce que vous voulez
si vous votez pour moi je ne peux te
croire monsieur du snob
je vous le promets c'est très simple
casimir je vaudrais pour toi si tu
retires ta candidature c'est tout oui
mais je voterai pour toi mais c'est
formidable
d'accord j'y vais j'y vais j'y vais je
vais retirer ma candidature je crois que
cette fois ci et casimir a été trop
démagogue puisqu'il retire sa
candidature personne ne votera pour lui
personne sauf moi bien sûr
qu'est ce que j'ai promis
bravo bravo cher bref encore une fois
mon cher président toutes mes
félicitations c'est mon ami merci
beaucoup je crois tu nous feras palais
chers amis j'aimerais quand même bien
savoir ce qui a décidé casimir a retiré
sa candidature et à vous laisser la
victoire
sauriez-vous quelque chose au moins non
vraiment je n'en ai pas la moindre idée
le tout cas heureusement pour vous qu il
l'a fait parce que je n'aurais pas eu le
courage de voter contre lui je comprends
très bien chère julie ce n'était pas la
peine j'étais sur les prêts lui j'ai été
chercher mon chapeau le président il est
beau n'est ce pas je vais faire un très
beau président mais enfin casimir tu a
retiré sa candidature
ouais et alors tu sais ce que ça veut
dire oui n'ont enfin pas très bien que
tu ne voulait plus qu'on vote pour toi
que je ne voulais plus être président
alors on enlever tous les bulles taton
non il ne restait plus que ceux de
monsieur du snap et tout le monde a voté
pour lui
ah bon tout le monde sauf moi j'ai tenu
ma promesse à jeu vient d'examiner les
bulletins de vote
monsieur du snop bien sûr est élu mais
casimir a une voix la mienne
comme promis
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai été un peu trop
démagogue haut que humide
[Musique]